hablemos de las noticias de la salud con
Mara Romero salamar Buenos días para
usted Buenos días Ángela Bueno vamos a
empezar hablando de Brasil el país el
que aprobó una nueva vacuna contra el
dengue y además hoy no estamos solas hoy
no estamos solas lo vamos a comentar con
nuestros asesores científicos se trata
de una vacuna desarrollada por
takedafarma que se administra en dos
dosis una gran noticia sobre todo para
un país como Brasil que es uno de los
que tiene más prevalencia del dengue y
como decíamos estamos con Carlos Eduardo
Pérez que es médico infectólogo de la
Universidad Nacional de Colombia que nos
acompaña para de tratar toda esta
noticia queríamos empezar por
preguntarle qué tan segura es esta
vacuna qué cifras arrojan los estudios
que se han hecho para saber que
efectivamente pues sirve para combatir
el dengue
Ángel amar Buenos días Sí mira uno de
los puntos importantes es que recordemos
que las vacunas son las que más estudian
en cuanto a seguridad esta vacuna es
aprobada nuevamente pero no es nueva ya
tiene recomendación de aprobación en
Europa y ya tiene estudios de seguridad
de más de cuatro años en donde en
población infantil ha mostrado que es
una vacunada efectiva pero sobre todo
que no hace años una vacuna Segura Y eso
es lo que ha dado aprobación pasó a la
aprobación en otros países y en este
caso Brasil dio ese paso para la
aprobación de esta vacuna para su
población infantil justamente doctora
Qué impacto tiene un fármaco de este
tipo en un sistema sanitario de un país
tan afectado y tan denso como es Brasil
es absolutamente tremenda el impacto lo
mismo que pasa en Brasil en otros países
de Centroamérica en Colombia Perú porque
recordemos que el dengue responsable más
o menos de 500.000 casos al año y cerca
de veinticinco mil a 30.000
fallecimientos por esta enfermedad
especialmente en la población infantil
en Brasil la extensión de su territorio
pues hace que sea una enfermedad alta
prevalencia y tener una vacuna es un
elemento más no el único pero un
elemento más para prevenir sobre todo el
desenlace fatal de la enfermedad Hay
unos dengues que tiene un comportamiento
benigno pero sobre todo en niños los
dengues tienen comportamiento que es un
comportamiento mucho más agresivo y que
puede llevar a un desenlace
doctor Esta es la segunda vacuna que
existe contra el dengue y una primera
hecha por el Instituto pasteur y
queríamos preguntarle Qué diferencias y
también Qué ventajas puede ofrecer esta
segunda vacuna respecto a la que ya
estaba aprobada desde 2015
hizo una vacuna que se aprobó hace unos
años la madre en base y esta vacuna es
una vacuna que requiere que la persona
se documente que ya ha tenido la
infección por dengue estas vacunas
tienen una plataforma de virus vivos y
para la vacuna de fiesta indispensable
saber si la que la persona ya haya
tenido al menos un episodio de infección
en la vacuna de takeda cero cero tres es
una vacuna que no se requiere que la
persona se documente que haya tenido la
infección y que protege para los cuatro
serotipos del dengue es decir es una
vacuna que no requiere Ese prerrequisito
es más segura y ya tiene esa aprobación
en población mayor de cuatro años es
decir prevención está previsto que esta
vacuna se apruebe en otros países
latinoamericanos o del mundo Qué sabe
usted doctor
Sí esa vacuna está sometida en países
del Trópico Colombia México
Centroamérica Perú Ecuador porque somos
una zona que tenemos esta enfermedad lo
mismo que pasa en el sudeste asiático y
Esperamos que esta vacuna y Este paso
que ahora sí pues ahora las puertas para
las nuevas aprobaciones que nosotros
países es una estrategia de la
vacunación la mejor vacunación es
protegernos erradicar el mosquito pero
si no se puede tener una vacuna
obviamente va a ser una medida que va a
cambiar la salud pública de nuestros
países también le queríamos a preguntar
mirando hacia el futuro no se prevé que
la crisis del dengue aumente a raíz del
cambio climático que llegue a otros
países o que se extienda a distintas
alturas Como por ejemplo en Colombia no
que llegue a ciudades más altas de las
que actualmente está afectando Cuál es
la importancia de tener vacunas así
listas para poder aplicarlas para poder
proteger a la población también mirando
hacia el futuro de un mundo donde el
dengue quizás sea incluso más preval
ente que ahora
las enfermedades transmitidas por
vectores estas por zancuditos por los
mosquitos son enfermedades que han
cambiado con el cambio climático y todos
tenemos unas altas prevalencias Pero que
están creciendo estas situaciones de
sequía de extrema lluvia de recolección
de agua hace que se precipiten estas
infecciones tener una vacuna para dengue
es un paso pero recordemos que el
chikungunya otras familias de arbovirus
también están creciendo tener métodos
diagnósticos oportunos y vacunas hacen
parte de la estrategia para prevenir
pero lo más importante es la
erradicación del vector es decir la
erradicación de los mosquitos y hacer
una adecuado programa de salud pública
para prevención sobre todo en la
población de la primera infancia pues
muchas gracias a usted doctor gracias a
usted Mary importante que tengamos estos
desarrollos no que podamos proteger a
una mayor cantidad de la población usted
lo repite constantemente en sus
intervenciones de salud es un gusto
También poder dar buenas noticias de vez
en cuando de vez en cuando gracias Mari
nos vemos mañana hasta mañana